-Welcome back to the show, and
congrats on getting married.
-Yes.
-This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It happened.
-Yep.
-This Thursday, you'll
be able to see the wedding
in the two-part finale
of "Paris in Love."
I have some photos here to show.
This is beautiful.
This is you at the altar.
-Yes.
-Gorgeous.
-I love that
Oscar de la Renta gown.
-Wowzers.
This is you and Carter
walking down the aisle.
-Mm-hmm.
-Look at this.
How was it? How was everything?
What went wrong?
[ Laughter ]
Something always goes
wrong at a wedding.
-It was magical.
It was everything.
I think the only thing I was
stressing out about was,
I hadn't written my vows
up until I was literally
about to walk down the aisle.
I was, like, rushing.
It was very stressful.
That's a lot of pressure.
Do you remember what you said?
-I just ended up throwing them
on the floor during my speech
and then just started speaking
from the heart.
So it went way better.
-Wow. Did you get emotional?
-He was crying
the entire time.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I am not ruining
this mascara and my gown,"
so I held it in.
-That's so funny.
Last time we talked, you said
you were gonna
make 10 outfit changes.
Did you?
-I wanted to live up to that,
but I only did seven.
[ Laughter ]
-But you did do it.
-Yeah.
-Was it tough to do,
to keep going and changing?
-Sort of.
It would have been tougher
to do at the Santa Monica Pier
for the Neon Carnival
because there's
nowhere to change.
But we had the wedding
at my grandfather's old estate,
so I just got dressed
in my old teenage room.
It was cute.
-Wow.
How about first dance?
Was that good, stress you out?
-That was the one thing
I was dreading,
because I hate ballroom dancing.
I'm good at, like, raving
and jumping around.
But, like, a fancy dance --
-Yeah, you can't do that.
-I was like, "I can't."
But I killed that, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. You're ridiculous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So funny.
Can you tell us
your first-dance song?
-Bruno Mars,
"Just the Way You Are."
-Aww.
-I love that song.
-Did you have any other song
under consideration?
-"Stars Are Blind," my song.
-Yeah!
-But Kim Petras sang it.
-That would have been great.
-She already sang it --
Kim Petras is my friend --
sand it as I was walking
down the aisle.
-She did?
-Yes.
-I ran into your mom,
by the way, who's super cute
and awesome and funny,
and she told me
that Demi Lovato crushed it.
-Oh, my God,
that was just so beautiful,
singing
"I Will Always Love You."
Everybody was crying.
-Demi Lovato is legit.
-So talented.
-I mean, pipes.
Yeah! Oh, that's so fun.
How was your mom
during the wedding?
-She was a lot of fun.
My mom --
No one knows how to throw
a party like my mom.
That's where I get it from.
-She seems fun.
-Yeah, she's so cool.
She loves you.
-She's great.
Also she's just a character.
She's so fun.
I mean, she's
the best thing on television.
-Thank you.
-I think she's
the funniest person.
I want to show everyone
a clip of your show.
This is Paris finding
wedding inspiration
in the craziest --
Where is this place?
-Las Vegas, Area15.
It's like an indoor Burning Man.
It's sick.
[ Laughter ]
-This is real.
Take a look at this.
-I've been going to Burning Man
for the past 10 years.
It's one of my favorite events.
It's so magical, and
it's like nothing on earth.
And Area15 is like
an indoor Burning Man.
So I thought, what a better way
to kick off the weekend?
No, I don't want to race.
-Oh!
♪♪
-Oh, babe, wait for me.
-Yes!
Oh, yes!
-It pays to go with
Paris Hilton to Vegas,
'cause they treat you
like the queen.
[ Both chuckle ]
-What is that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's amazing. You have to go.
-I have to go to that place.
Last time you were on the show,
I asked you to explain NFTs.
And you did so in a great way,
which is a very hard thing
to really explain
to a lot of people.
But since then, "Forbes"
has named you
one of the top 50
most influential people
in the NFT space.
So congrats on that.
-Thank you.
Thank you. I'm so proud.
I love being
part of this community
and being a voice and
sharing my platform
and just getting the word
out there,
because I think it's just
such an incredible thing
to be a part of.
-Yeah, I jumped in.
-I know, I heard.
I'm so happy
I taught you what they were.
-You did.
You taught me what's up.
And then I bought an ape.
-I got an ape, too,
because I saw you on the show
with Beeple,
and you got on Moonpay,
so I went and I copied you
and did the same thing.
-You did?
-Mm-hmm.
-This is your ape.
-Yeah, it's really cool.
Look at the hat, the shades.
-How did you pick --
because you can pick your ape.
-Yes. I was going through
a lot of them.
And I was like,
"I want something
that kind of reminds me of me,"
but this one, it does.
I think we made, like,
another version of it,
where he takes the hat off
and blond hair comes out.
-Ah, 'cause you can do now
whatever you want.
-Mm-hmm. Animated version.
-We're part of the community.
We're both apes.
-I love it.
-Here's my ape. This is my ape.
-Yours is so cool.
I love the red heart sunglasses.
I love the captain hat.
-It reminded me of me
a little bit,
because I wear striped shirts.
-Mm-hmm.
I've worn
these heart sunglasses,
'cause my daughters,
just as a joke --
they have them, and as a joke,
I've put them on.
So, I've done this.
And I love Yacht Rock
and being breezy.
So I'm like, "Yeah."
And I like the blue.
-Mm-hmm.
-Dude, look at this.
-They looks like
they could be
friends.
-They're buddies.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
But this is --
you have a new NFT.
You have one
being released soon.
We have it here.
What can you tell us about this?
-Well, it's an NFT series
I'm doing with Superplastic.
And we're releasing
on Origin Protocol.
And then I made
another piece by hand.
Took me six months.
And it's a collage
of all of my memories
with Carter.
And it's called
"My Forever Fairytale."
-Wow.
And here's the actual collage.
-Yes.
-This is big.
I think people
are gonna love this.
-Well, if you love it so much,
I actually want to give you
the first one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mm-hmm.
-I would be honored.
-And I want to give one
to everyone in the audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everyone gets an NFT?
-Yes, everyone.
-Everyone gets an NFT tonight!
Paris!
Come on!
I think that's
the NFT giveaway
in television history.
We love you!
-Iconic!
-Paris Hilton!
Who else does that?
-Love you guys.
-Paris and I
will do something fun
after the break.
We have a very special guest
to help us out.
Stick around.
For real? We all get them?